Sys wizard app is powerful and dangerous. Uh
Sometimes you need to do something to your system. Normally
you might. Sometimes you need to do something with your
system. You need to install something or figure out what's
using all the disk space or Something else that you
might normally go to the command line for. However, with
AI and Cognotic, you can have an LLM write the
shell script for you. You start with the, you start
at the goal tab of the system wizard and type
in what you want to do. Let's for this demonstration
do. Listen. Running
What's the running processes. You saved the goal. We are
using Windows here. This also supports Shell, which is Linux
or Mac OS. It specifically uses Bash, but we're going
to be using Windows and PowerShell. We List running processes
In settings we make sure that we have a model
selected. We have Gemini 3 Flash Preview we're going to
use in this demo, and then we go to the
pipeline and generate the shell script. That
And here we go. We can either use this directly
in our own show or we can click run and
fix to test the script. Now
in this run and autofix session that appears, If
an error occurs, it will look into the error and
then Try to code up a fix. If an error
were to happen, you would be able to run again
Well, you would be able to. Fixed it. You would
be able to retry the execution in this interface. However
the first execution was successful, and it is listing all
the processes that we can view here. The UI shows
that the command succeeded. Note that the UI does not
show the output of the command. You have to go
into the session rank to view that detail. And there
you go. That is the system wizard. That is the
System Wizard application. I hope you find it useful.